francesco rizzuto professeur de droit
européen université de hadji le royaume
uni bonsoir francesco rizzuto merci
d'être avec nous alors outre-manche
quelle est la réaction de la population
à ce qu'elle est choquée en sélection
les derniers sondages suggèrent que 70%
environ des personnes interrogées
pensent que dominique amyot moussa a
fait quelque chose de répréhensible
je pense qu'au vu de la gravité de ce
que les britanniques comme il subit et
sachant que d'autres personnes qui
conseille le gouvernement notamment le
gouvernement écossais ont démissionné
après avoir violé les règles du
confinement les perses les gens ne sont
pas très contents
il faudrait que le parti conservateur
soit également de l'avis de cette
mission mais il ya beaucoup de silence
ce côté ci cette démission de donal
donnait perdant de glace grossesse
qu'elle marque les esprits quelles en
sont les conséquences
ce gouvernement est un nouvelle posture
ils essayent de protéger quelqu'un dont
on attend beaucoup de personnes au parti
conservateur se méfie n'ont aucune envie
de protéger
lorsqu'on est au sommet du gouvernement
il faut respecter la lettre et l'esprit
de la loi et beaucoup de personnes ont
beaucoup souffert
le député qui a démissionné l'a fait
pour une question de principe et je
pense qu'ils avaient raison pour le
gouvernement de boris c'est très grave
vous avez dit pas vraiment beaucoup de
réactions de la part des politiques
notamment celle de
boris johnson qui a pourtant lui était
directement touchés par le le covin 19
il aurait dû avoir une autre attitude
selon vous un député de nombreux du
parlement beaucoup d'autres personnes
sont appelées à la résignation de mika
ming un député a démissionné s'il domine
comme il s'était excusé dimanche s'il
avait accepté le fait qu'il avait fait
une erreur
les gens auraient compris très bien et
il souhaitait et prendre soin de son
enfant mais il n'y avait aucun regret il
n'y avait aucune excuse il a dit je ne
regrette rien je n'ai rien fait de mal
parce que les gens ne peuvent même pas
se rendre à l'enterrement de leurs
proches et que un des membres du
gouvernement qui a aidé à définir les
règles du jeu n'ai rien fait de mal
alors il ya un gros problème c'est vrai
que comparé à la france je me garderai
bien de demain elle est sur des terrains
trop glissant mais c'est vrai que ce
devoir d'exemplarité de la classe
politique peut surprendre il est rare qu
en france on a guetté l'emploi du temps
d'un ministre en plein confinement alors
qu'effectivement les français étaient
sans arrêt pris en faute et se retrouver
avec des pv
s'il était en fraude grave à vue où je
ne prétend pas savoir une opinion sur la
situation en france mais je pense qu'en
période de crise il est crucial que les
personnes qui gouvernent les
personnalités publiques montrent
l'exemple
si ce n'est pas le cas en france cela
devrait l'être et les médias français
devrait peut être faire plus attention à
ce que le dirigeant fond on ne peut pas
dire aux gens de faire quelque chose et
ne pas le faire soi même ne peut pas y
avoir deux poids deux mesures merci en
tout cas francesco rizzotto d'avoir été
avec nous nous avoir apporté votre
analyse